[MUSIC]
I went to my first AA meeting
when I was seven years old, and
I know what you guys are thinking,
what the hell was in this girl's
baby bottle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Spoiler alert,
I was not an alcoholic at age seven.
My uncle took me to that AA meeting
because there are people in my family
who were.
In fact, there are people in my family
suffering from many forms of addiction.
Knowing that addiction would
dramatically affect my life,
he wanted me to be informed about it.
So he exposed me to addiction,
from the viewpoint of an addict, so
that I could understand their struggle.
According to the Center of Addiction,
40 million Americans are suffering
from substance addiction.
This includes alcohol,
illicit drugs and prescription opioids.
40 million.
That's nearly one in every eight people.
Look at your row.
On average,
at least one person is addicted.
138 million Americans
have a close friend or family member
who is suffering from addiction.
That's nearly 50% of our entire
country who knows an addict.
And yet, due to shame, people that
know an addict never talk about it.
They hide it from their friends,
they hide it from their neighbors,
they even hide it from
other family members.
People who know an addict go through
great lengths to keep this secret.
I know because up until this talk,
I was one of these people.
Drug addiction is defined by the National
Institute for Drug Abuse as a complex,
chronic brain disease characterized
by drug craving, seeking and use.
The key to this craving is dopamine.
Dopamine is the neurotransmitter in your
brain that's responsible for pleasure.
Totally natural and necessary function.
Dopamine surges happen when you're
watching a movie you really love, or
even foods that you enjoy,
perhaps chocolate or pasta.
Or when you're having sex,
well, hopefully.
>> [LAUGH]
>> When you consume drug,
over time it overstimulates
the dopamine in your system causing
a euphoric effect that is 2 to 10 times
the amount that your body is used to.
This is the high, but over time
when you continue to consume drugs,
the surges in dopamine really make it
difficult to participate in life fully.
This is why, when addicts aren't using
drugs, they complain of feeling flat,
lifeless, and depressed all the time.
At this point it stops being
about using drugs to get high and
starts being about using
drugs just to feel normal.
An addict needs substances to
reach the same levels of dopamine
as a non-drug user.
Addiction literally rewires your brain.
Addiction is not a choice.
This is literally a brain disease.
So the question then becomes,
if research has proven that addiction
is not a choice but a brain disease.
How in the United States do
we justify putting addicts in
prisons instead of treatment centers?
Would we put cancer patients in
prison because they have cancer?
Of course not.
65% of prison inmates
are clinically addicted.
Many of them were convicted for personal
drug use, not even intent to sell.
We put addicts in prison for
the compulsive use of a drug that their
brain literally tells them
that they need to survive.
But this is not just about
an increase in the prison population.
Addiction cause our economy a lot
of money, $520 billion to be exact,
this is the cost to our economy
in lost work productivity,
healthcare expenses, criminal justice
cost, and law enforcement cost.
And the problem is only growing
Opiod addiction alone has grown
by 493% in the last seven years.
The US Surgeon General has declared
opiod addiction a public health crisis
that is both underappreciated and
undertreated.
Do addicts choose to try these substances?
Yes, were they coerced into trying them?
Probably not, but does that mean that
they choose an entire life of addiction?
No, no one grows up and says, I really,
really want to be
an addict when I get older.
They just don't.
I've spoken to you guys
today about a number of
statistics but
addiction is not statistics.
Addiction is the mother
who lies to her family and
friends because she is too ashamed to
admit that her son has a drug problem.
Addiction is the father who
steals from his kids piggy banks
to feed his drug habit.
Addiction is being called by the police
to identify your sister's body,
because she just overdosed.
These are not examples that I made up.
These are examples from
people that I know,
some of whom are in this room right now.
My uncle took me to that AA
meeting when I was seven,
because he knew what I did not know.
My mother was addicted to crack.
Like many addicts, she was unreliable,
she was irresponsible,
and when I was four,
she stopped caring for me altogether.
Growing up as a child of an addict is
a very painful and traumatic experience.
You live in secrecy mortified that
people would judge you for this disease.
So you do everything you
can to keep it hidden.
When I was little, I used to just think
if I could just get more straight As or
more awards,
she would want to be my mom again.
I didn't understand how my mom could
want a drug more than she wanted me.
I recently re-met my mom after 23 years.
People ask me how do
you forgive an addict?
How do you forgive addiction?
Understanding that this not a choice, but
literally a brain disease,
is a critical step.
I wasn't sure how to give this talk today,
because the topic is so
taboo and so personal, but
there are literally 40 million Americans
that are suffering from this disease.
And if we do not start treating this
like the health issue that it really is,
we are further enabling a disease
that is killing thousands,
destroying families all over this country,
and has a real economic cost.
We, as a society, have to make a paradigm
shift into how we are addressing
addiction, one that creates more
patients and fewer prisoners.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]